this is maybe the visit this talks a
little more from the computer science
perspective and and many of the talks
we've had this week so we talking about
how to compute the various pollen
polynomials that we've been seeing this
week and should say you know when I was
thinking about what to say I I asked I
asked Shia and you know what what what
does he expect me to talk about and I
was expecting a short little list and he
sent me a complete lecture plan so I'm
following following Cheyennes like to
plan so if you don't like it you can you
know who to blame okay so and I also
want to shout out to to my students who
to the extent I understand any of this
it's largely due to them Poosh is here
as a fellow the semester graduated a few
years ago is now at the Tata Institute
and Jing Chang is currently a student
graduating this year and looking for
jobs okay so so I want to talk about a
class of polynomials that would call
partition functions and they show up in
motivated from statistical physics so in
a statistical physical system called the
spin system it's a discrete model that
lives on some some finite graph and it
has configurations which assigned to
each vertex of the graph one of a
certain finite family of spins so sexy
spins one through Q so configuration is
just an assignment of colors or whatever
you like to the vertices of the graph
and then each such assignment has has an
energy which we'll call H and the energy
has two components one component comes
from pairwise interactions so you look
at every pair of
neighboring vertices and look at their
spins and there's some edge potential
that tells you for any given pair of
spins what the contribution is to the
entity and similarly only on every
vertex there is a potential that just
depends on the spin of that vertex and
when you okay so the statistical
mechanics the key object is the gibbs
distribution which which are called mu
and this assigns to every configuration
a probability that depends on its energy
basically it's a e to the minus the
energy of the configuration okay and
then there's a normalizing factor in
that distribution this Z which will be
you be talking about throughout this
afternoon so this Z is the sum of e to
the minus H all right and this is what
I'll call the partition function that
isn't immediately a polynomial but if
you change variable and you get a pom
note and it was we'll see in a minute
okay so another thing we're going to be
sick of by the end of this afternoon is
the easing model okay so the easing
model is a particular spin system in
which are only two spins plus one and
minus one and the energy of a given
configuration is okay so you so you
basically have a contribution of minus B
if the two if both of the vertices on an
edge have the same spin and plus B if
they have different spin okay and then
there's also an external field which
measures the just the total sum of all
the spins so the partition like you're
just writing down but I had on the
previous slide
you get this form and so to make this
look nicer we're just going to perform a
transformation in which beta is e to the
minus 2b lambda Z to the 2a
pull out a factor that is I guess I
should have included this factor there's
an easily computable factor at the front
here that just depends on the number of
edges and the number of vertices
basically you're going to get a
contribution of a factor of beta for
every cut edge between plus and minus
vertices every edge that is connects a
plus vertex to a minus vertex and you're
also going to get a factor of lambda
rate for every plus vertex in there okay
so let me go through that a little
example
oh and so really this is a this is a cut
generating polynomial right because
we're some s is the set of plus vertices
with something over over cuts right
partitions of V into plus and minus and
we're and we're allocating each cut a
weight of beta to the number of cut
edges times lambda to the to the size of
one side of the cut here's a little
example this guy has three plus vertices
and it has five cut edges so this will
this will show up in the polynomial the
weight of B to the five times lambda
cubed
yeah so so looking at it as a cut
generating polynomial we sum over all we
sum over cuts giving each cut away to
beter to the K where K is the number of
edges in the cut and gamma K is the
coefficient which counts them by weight
weighted according to how large each
side is now there's a fundamental
difference between two different regimes
here so if we take beta less than one
which is equivalent in the original
parameterization to be greater than zero
then we're dealing with a ferromagnetic
model which means that it favors small
cuts so configurations with largest
weight will be those in which all the
vertices try to be this have the same
side and conversely if you take P 2
greater than 1 you're favoring large
cuts and therefore you want to get lots
of alternations between pluses and
minuses and the physics terminology this
is called a ferromagnetic model
everybody is trying to be the same anti
ferromagnetic model everybody is trying
to different from their neighbors I've
absorbed the lambda into the gammak yeah
ok so that so now looking at it as a
polynomial of Justin just in lambda with
the beta as fixed inside here will be a
sum over all possible values of the of
the size of the of the number of guys on
one side of the cut this is a this is a
polynomial in lambda
I see I'm sorry you're absolutely right
this this should be this should be this
should be a beta and this should be
alumni apologize
yeah I'm sorry most of the time I'm
gonna be okay
so so this polynomial here it's a
polynomial in two variables and it's
going to be convenient for us to look at
it either as a polynomial in beta with
lambda fixed or as a polynomial and it
would be difficult not going to talk
about detail which will no doubt come up
tomorrow and and throughout the semester
so for example in the Potts model
instead of just having two spins it's
like it's like an e generalization of
easing model in which you have two
different spins you have a field
associated with each spin and again you
you are looking at cuts so you see you
count edges that connect two unequal
spins so it's like a queue way cut
generating polynomial the Hardcore model
as the configurations are independent
sets in the graphs you have to spin 0
and 1 you're not allowed to ones next to
each other so the allowable
configurations are independent sets in
the graph and you weight each
independent set I lambda to it to its
size okay and this is a if all of these
things can be realized by suitable
potentials and finally mono medina model
where this is strictly speaking not a
spin system because it's a model on
edges but you you assign zero or one to
each edge of the graph and you you're
allowed configurations on matchings and
the graphs of independent sets of edges
and again you raise each to the power
lambda to its you you weight each by
lambda to the power of its size and
these are this is really just the
matching polynomial
all right so why partition functions
important so they show up in these
physical models more generally as we've
seen the easing example they're they're
a generalization of counting problems so
you you're just you're looking at
basically combinatorial generate
generating functions as we've seen there
the denominator in the gibbs
distribution now something that's a
little less obvious is that their
derivatives are actually observables in
physical systems so if you look at the
derivative of the respect to each of the
logarithm of the using partition
function you're you're so you're going
to get a 1 over Z alright and then
you're going to get because in the
exponent you've got a the field term H
times the sum of the spins this will
come down when you take the derivative
and so what you're left with is the
expectation over the Gibbs Distribution
that this this is the Gibbs weight of a
configuration this is the dome and this
is the normalizing factor so you get the
expectation and the gibbs distribution
of this observable which is the sum of
the spins and so so generally speaking
and this is called the magnetization
that's the total sum of the spins so
generally speaking because of the form
of a part of a other gibbs distribution
where the energy sits in the exponent
derivatives of log z with respect to you
know the various potential parameters H
or B or whatever will always give rise
to an expectation of some kind of
natural observable in the system some
function of the spins or the pairs of
spins so that's another reason why these
partition functions are important and
finally something that I'll be spending
quite a bit of time on today is the Z
the partition banging is connected
closely with phase transitions in the
model which you'll see in a minute
okay so so what about computing these
these polynomials so essentially any
interesting accounting problem in this
class any interesting evaluation problem
for these polynomials is intractable in
exact form so it's number be hard to
compute for example the easing partition
function except at a very small number
of more or less trivial points that in
b201 or lenses these are extremals cases
of infinite field or zero potential so
so and and they're hard even point wise
so you don't even have to play with the
beaten and the lambda to make them hard
and for those of you don't not aware of
number P hardness I mean it's it's an
analogue of NP hardness or NP
completeness for counting problems so to
just saying that's a proving that a
problem is NP r--'s number P hard is
tantamount to saying that we don't
expect it to be solvable in polynomial
time without a major breakthrough in
complexity theory so therefore the game
becomes trying to approximate the
partition functions and the gold
standard here is is something called a
horrible acronym FP tears or FP res
right so that the difference between the
T in the R is R stands for randomized t
just stands for x there's a fully
polynomial time approximation scheme
probably pulling in real time
randomized approximations so these are
algorithms that approximates the about
as well as you can expect so they you
give them the input of the graph you
also give them an accuracy parameter and
an absolute accuracy parameter Epsilon
and you require an estimate that's
within a 1 plus or minus epsilon of the
true value of the partition function and
wherever your running time should be
polynomial not only in the size of the
input but also in 1 over epsilon so as
you as you require more and more
accuracy your running time
blow up in a horrible way now this is it
turns out this is not an arbitrary
definition I mean in fact unlike
approximation guarantees and
optimization problems it turns out this
is in fact for a wide class of partition
functions this is a robust notion so if
I give you any kind of semi decent
approximation algorithm before a
partition function then I can boot
bootstrap it to one that satisfies this
condition so one that is arbitrarily
good okay and by up by by a semi-decent
approximation algorithm I would mean one
that has maybe a polynomial here like n
to the 100 so you can approximate Z
within an end to the 100 factor then it
can be bootstrap to walk to such an
approximation at least with
randomization hmm a couple of other
remarks that'll come up so if we want to
approximate Z then it's enough to just
calculate the marginal at a given vertex
so if you just if you've got an easing
model if you can compute at any given
vertex the probability that it's plus
then that can be recursively applied to
compute the entire partition function
and similarly if you can randomly sample
from the Gibbs distribution then you can
get an approximation algorithm for the
partition function just by this
observation so if I couldn't take random
samples from the partition function from
the Gibbs distribution then I can
compute the margin or the vertex and
there and thereby the whole partition
function
okay right so now I want to talk a
little bit about phase transitions so
one way to think about phase transitions
is that somehow if you just specify the
local potentials of the the model then
as the size of the system goes to
infinity they're not they are not enough
to determine the macroscopic properties
of the system so somehow there's there's
some some non determinacy as as the
system goes to infinity so let's say
we'll make that precise the moment or
more precisely learning
and classically there are there are two
characterizations of phase transition
that float around so one of them is is a
probabilistic notion so in common
listing notion you think of your your
finite you think of a sequence of finite
graphs going to infinity and you imagine
putting different boundary conditions
around the outside and as as as your
graph goes to infinity the Gibbs measure
that's induced will actually depend on
the boundary condition so there isn't a
unique Gibbs measure induced by by the
boundary conditions and the second
notion is an analytic one and this
refers to the partition function said
having zeros in the complex plane so
it's not immediately obvious why complex
values should be relevant at all here
because I mean after all everything is
real but we'll see in a moment why this
shows up so these are two different
notions of a phase transition yeah
Sorry Sorry everything is real so it's
not relevant white why having zeros in
the always had zeroes of the complex
playing but the question is in what in
what domain it has a zero yeah so the
absence of zeros in certain ranges of
parameters okay so so the the rule of
thumb is that if you have so since we're
talking about computation rule of thumb
is that if you have phase transitions a
phase if you have a phase transition in
the model then this should show up
computationally as making the
computation of the partition function
harder so in particular we'll see that
certain local algorithms fail and
sometimes even the problem becomes a
computationally intractable when you
when you when you have a phase
transition okay so let's look at this in
the case of the easing model and and
let's let's look at the easing model a
special case on on the infinite d
dimensional Cartesian lattice CD and
we're going to look at this as the limit
of finite graphs so a limit of n to n my
limit of boxes - n - n to the D and it
turns out that at zero field when it so
when H is zero the easing model exhibits
a phase transition when the interaction
parameter B is above a certain critical
value which depends on the dimension
okay and not otherwise this is the only
place where you get a phase transition
so that's briefly and that this is all
this is this can all be made rigorous so
it's not
I haven't spelled out details at all but
this is just to give an idea here so
first of all let's look at the
probabilistic characterization of the
phase transition so you look at your box
and you you in one case you look at
putting plus boundaries around the box
the other case you put minus boundaries
around the box and you let the box go to
infinity and you look at what the
what's the magnetization at the origin
so what's the what's the probability
what's the expected value of the spin at
the origin and it turns out that if when
when B is bigger than B the critical
then these two values are different so
you actually get a small positive or
it's a positive spin here and then
negative spin here it is I think true at
the critical point yeah okay so what it
means is that even as the boundary
recedes to infinity the there is a a non
there is a non vanishing effect of the
boundary felt at the origin okay so for
the analytic characterization of the
phase transition we look at the quantity
that's sometimes called the pressure
which is log of basically log of the
partition function normalized by the
volume so that it's a something that has
that stays finite so let's call that
that quantity psi okay turns out that
this this limit always exists and it's
independent of the boundary condition so
you don't have to specify the boundary
conditions and so so remember from a few
slides ago that the derivative of log Z
is just the magnetization and we're just
normalizing it so it's the magnetization
per per site so when for finite volumes
this this quantity is just the the
expected magnetization density of
magnetization per site so if if this guy
is differentiable what we'd expect is
that it so it it's derivative exists so
and then if we're lucky we can
interchange the derivative and the limit
and we should get that the the
derivative is equal to the limit limit
of the magnetization density okay which
I'll call them of pH okay so this is
this condition is really saying that the
the observable end the magnetization
behaves
in the limit and in fact for the easing
model on CD these two these two these
two characterizations of the phase
transition happen to be equivalent
because you can show that the right side
that so the right and left sided
derivatives of the pressure always exist
and the right derivative is equal it
actually is equal to the limit of the
magnetization with a plus boundary and
the left derivative is equal to the
limit of the of the magnetization and
the minus boundary and so it's the
derivative exists then then these two
left and right derivatives are equal and
therefore the magnetization Tzar equal
and therefore in particulars the spin at
the origin is equal so the Gibbs may and
that's enough to in fact tell you that
the Gibbs measures are the same so you
have this picture for beta less than the
critical value the this mean
magnetization behaves nicely everywhere
for beta above the critical value it's
not defined at 0 ok so that H equals 0
is where you have a phase transition and
you have different values of them of the
mean magnetization according to whether
you're in the plus pound real minus
boundary or equivalently whether you're
taking this derivative from the left or
the right
that's very roughly their connection so
how do we use all this to to to actually
how do we use these characterizations to
prove the existence of a phase
transition well for proving that there
is a phase transition at h equals 0 you
can typically use the probabilistic
characterization you explicitly analyze
the limit of the of the magnetization at
the origin with a plus boundary and show
that it goes to 0 when when B is small
and and and that it stays away from 0
and B is large ok and this this
establishes the existence of the phase
transition at age equals 0
I think I want to focus on their is how
do we show this that's the only bad
point how do we show that there's no
phase transition when H is nonzero and
this is where I'm a long long route
there but this is where I finally want
to make a connection with with zeros and
complexity isn't a complex plane so so
to show there's no phase transition for
H non zero we have to show that this
this function Tsai is differentiable
when H is nonzero now this was this is a
famous Liang program from the 50s and
you know that first they prove did a
general fact which is that so we want to
show that that this function Phi which
is the limit of log Z is is
differentiable and it turns out that
it's sufficient to show that Z itself
has no zeros okay so you want to find a
region in the complex plane D such that
Z itself has no zeros in that region and
this is this is just for the finite Z so
this is going to give us a finite volume
condition to check so if you have such
an if you have a simply connected open
region that contains an interval of the
real line which is the the piece you're
interested in and if you want to show
that that Tsai is differentiable you've
actually you actually can show it some
analytic in this whole volume D provided
you can show that Z has no Z that there
any of the finite aziz have no zeros in
that region
okay and then the thing that really
makes this powerful is what they've been
proved and this is what I call the Li
yang theorem so what they showed was
that in the the easing model for any for
any value of B the only zeros of the
finite volume partition function indeed
this holds not just an ZD this holds for
any graph at all so for any finite graph
G the only zeros of the partition
function must have a real value of zero
it can only lie on the imaginary axis
and so this this so applying the
previous general fact with D being say
the right-hand half plane this this will
tell us that size is and will they take
on its real analytic on this axis and
therefore there's no phase transition so
what what so what this condition does is
it allows us to replace the thorny a
problem of showing that upside as a real
function is differentiable and on the
real axis by the supposedly easier
problem of showing that Z sorry I'm
showing that ya Z has no zeros in the
complex plane
certainly does he has no zeros in
accomplished okay so
so let me write so the first actual math
we're going to do is to prove this
theorem so to prove the Liang theorem
and it's slightly easier to use the
alternative parameterization so let's
let's I think I've got this the right
way around this time so I want to view Z
as a function just of lambda because
remember we're looking at analyticity
and H which and H corresponds to lambda
under the change of variable so now
looking at this this polynomial which I
and I'll absorb this just as a as a
coefficient so I'm looking at a
polynomial in lambda and the claim is
now that we've changed variable rather
than showing that the zeros lie on the
imaginary axis we need we're going to
have to show that they lie on the unit
circle in the complex plane so so the
claim for the yang is for any graph and
any value of the interaction parameter
beta all the complex zeros lie on the
unit circle
there's an obligatory joke that comes up
when you talk about the liang theorem
which which is that lien yang lin yang
who won the nobel prize not for this but
for other work of the day after the
nobel prize was announced the Chinese
restaurant in Manhattan where they met
up to do a lot of their work put it put
a sign like this in the window and even
these sales were boosted among those who
know what Nobel Prizes okay so okay so
let lets let's prove the li yang theorem
so remember this is an extremely general
effect so it's this holds for any an
arbitrary finite graph G and we have
this this the the polynomial on from the
previous slide write this polynomial and
I'm going to do in order to prove this
we're going to consider the multivariate
version of that polynomial so now I'm
going to give a different variable
lambda to each vertex of the graph and
so this will be there this will be the
result of the form of the polynomial n
here is the number of vertices in the
graph and I claim it's sufficient to
show the point so we want to let's let's
define let's say the polynomial is Li
yang a multivariate polynomial is Li
yang if it has the following property
that if all of the lambdas are in the
absolute value bigger than once they all
lie outside the unit circle then the
polynomial is nonzero okay so this so if
we if we project back down to the
univariate version we said all the
lambda is to be equal to lambda then it
says that if land is outside the unit
circle we have no zeros and then by
symmetry of between lambda and 1 over
lambda so this pot this polynomial is
symmetric in lambda 1
because because basically the you're
either looking at one side of the card
or the other side of the cut okay so so
particulars easy of lambda is just
lambda to the N times e of one over
lambda and so it's fighters to show that
there are no zeros outside the unit
circle which implies immediately there
are no zeros inside the unit circle okay
so we're getting so this is what we want
to show okay so so this this goes by a
nice a nice induction arg and a
combinatorial induction element there
are many proofs of this actually the
original proofs were much less common at
Oriel but this this proof is typical
this proof is attributed to Asano
originally so so how do we prove this so
we start off with the base case which is
a single edge so our graph just consists
of a single edge or two parameters a
lambda 1 and a lambda 2 and let's write
down the partition function so what's
what's the partition function for this
for this simple graph well there are 4 a
site there are four configurations right
plus plus plus minus minus plus and
minus minus so the plus plus
configuration will give us a lambda 1
lambda 2 term right because 2 2 pluses
the two configurations plus minus and
minus plus each of them will pick up a
factor of beta from the the cut edge
between plus and minus one of them will
get a lambda 1 for this guy being plus
the other one got a lambda 2 for this
guy being plus and then the minus minus
configuration will give us a 1 because
there are no cut edges and no plus
vertices ok so this is the partition
function and now for the partition
function to have a 0 it must be the case
that just solving the equation lambda 2
has to be equal to this ratio here so so
this thing is a Mabius transform and
that's
the the exterior of the unit disk to the
interior so if lambda 1 is outside the
unit circle then lambda 2 has to be
inside the unit cell and therefore we if
they're both outside we cannot have a 0
second simple ingredient is that if if G
and H of vertex disjoint graphs and
their partition functions are zg in Z H
if each of them separately is Li yang
then since they're the partition
function of the union of the two graphs
is just the product of their partition
functions this is easily obviously also
Li yang finally we've got the the
inductive step which involves merging
merging vertices together so we're going
to build up any graph using front from
the bit from a single edge using this
operation so if we at some point have
two vertices one with a parameter lambda
1 the other with parameter lambda 2 and
we're going to merge them together into
a single vertex like this with parameter
lambda hmm so we want to show that if if
this inductively is Li yang then this
then this polynomial resulting from the
merge is also Liang so the the polling
right so let's fix all of the other fix
the values on all the other vertices and
all in the in the regime are interested
in so they're all outside the unit
circle then by our inductive assumption
the partition function of this thing is
it has the Li yang property so these
coefficients a b c and d are just
computed from what from the effect of
the rest of the graph okay okay so these
are these are some coefficients on the
rest of the graph and we'll have a term
you know for both being plus a term for
one being plus warming - term for one
wing - all in class and the term for
both being - so we get a polynomial of
this form
and since this is this has the li yang
property we know that this this this
polynomial cannot be zero if both
lambda1 and lambda2 outside the unit is
since all the other variables are
already outside the unit disk and so i'm
inducting on this graph already Bingley
there's this partition function already
Bingley yang and I can write that
partition function in this form
I'll put it all together on the next
side but yeah so okay let's let's look
at this first and right so so you start
to see to get it to get your final graph
start off with a bunch of independent
edges each one is Lee Young we know and
then their product is Lee Young and they
emerge them one by one to get the girl
okay yes I should have put this up first
alright so okay so now we're interested
in the case where you know that lambda 1
lambda 2 are going to be merged so
they'll have a common value lambda so
we'll make that substitution so we
certainly know from from this fact we
know that this guy doesn't have any
zeros right if lambdas outside the unit
circle and therefore this is just a
quadratic polynomial so the product of
its zeros is da over a right and so it
so since since since since it's since
since its zeros must be less than or
equal to one D over a must be less than
or equal to 1 and therefore the the new
part the new partition function that we
get here right which is after all just a
lambda plus D right because the
contributions from configurations in
which lambda 1 and lambda 2 are
different right so these contributions
go away so the new partition function on
the right hand side has the Leong
property
now there's a there's a right so detail
here that we're dividing by a so you
also have to check inductively that a is
nonzero which can be can be checked as
we go through by it by a similar
induction so the proof is very simple
okay before moving on from this I wanted
to yeah okay so that in a so that
definitely you know establishes the lack
of a phase transition for positive field
for the easing model but it's also you
know a very finite result that we can
use and we will on the later on which we
can use computationally for finite
graphs that have nothing to do with ZD
okay so I just wanted to before moving
on from the yang I wanted to mention a a
little spin off from it which may or may
not be interesting so you can so it's
interesting as we know it's interesting
to think about what happens if we if we
when studying geometry of polynomials
it's interesting to think about what
happens to the zeros of the polynomials
when under natural operations and one of
which is taking derivative so we know
that this polynomial Z has the Liang
property so it's zeroes lie on the on
the unit circle what happens what
happens where do the zeros of its
derivative life hmm and it turns out
that you can prove that provided the
graph is connected the zeros lie
strictly inside the unit circle not they
lie strictly inside so you know the
Gauss Lucas theorem will tell you that
the zeros of the derivative line the
convex hull of the of the original zeros
but that doesn't that doesn't actually
show that they that doesn't preclude
them being you know actually coincident
with these points or equivalently of Z
having multiple zeros there is a
multiplicity bigger than one so so as a
result so having one see once you prove
that and
the proof of that goes via a an argument
that's quite similar but basically
follows the asano construction though
it's a little more technical and one of
the exercises we look at look at the
base case of this it's a quick
equivalent statement is that Z has no
multiple zeros and notice it's trivial
that you need connectedness here because
otherwise you just take two copies of
the same graph and they obviously it
obviously has multiple zeros all beated
while ferromagnetic so beta has to be
zero and one yeah it doesn't hold for an
anti firm it yeah that was a sorry I
guess I mean that this maybe it's
transformed here right only has has this
property when Peters between 0 & 1
mm-hmm okay so
not that I'm aware of nice structure of
it hmm well there's four the independent
set sorry
and then okay so now it's it so for the
experts and in mmm no geometry of
polynomials I'd be curious to know
whether this fact is interest and if so
you know what come on do with it I can
tell you one thing you can do with it
from a complexity theoretic point of
view so the fact that the fact that the
derivative of Z and Z itself have no
common zeros allows you to show that
complexity theoretically computing the
mean magnetization is just as hard as
computing the partition function so so
the remember that the mean magnetization
is that the expected okay it can be
written as basically the ratio of the
magnetization is the derivative mean
magnetization as the derivative divided
by Z right so that's the quantity of
interest we have an extra factor of
lambda here because we've changed
we've changed parameters from from H to
that for it from from e to the H to
lambda so that that just naturally shows
up so the point is that suppose I want
to show you that computing the
magnetization is just as hard as
computing this denominator here then
that could be that there are magical
cancellations that make this an easier
quantity to compute than this in
particular when lambdas one this is
trivial to compute so is that is that
something that I mean when when lambdas
one you have zero field and therefore by
symmetry the magnetization is just zero
okay so is that is it can any can this
can this be easy to compute for any
other reason so the answer's no
immediately from the fact we just
established that so the fact that for
zeros of this guy lie inside the unit
circle while the zeros of this guy lie
on the unit circle means that they share
no have no common zeros and therefore
you can use rational interpolation to
compute to compute
these two polynomials given an
evaluation of this problem a bunch of
evaluations of this polynomial so you
you deduce that computing this thing is
number be hard at all
at all points to say all interesting
points even on bounded degree graph ok
so that's yeah not that I'm aware I mean
analog of what this or and the Liang
theorem or not that I'm aware of I mean
there's a there's a there are things
that say which grow which which types of
systems satisfied all the young property
and they're fairly restrictive we have
three-way interactions I don't think
oh I see yes true yeah good point yeah
so so so for that's true yes so for
hypergraphs you can also prove Liang
theorem but the range of beaters that
you can handle depends on the size of
the exercise I think this asana proof is
also around well
right so so this point now is get I've
run out of slide so it's going to now
switch to the board there's also the
exercise I don't know let me let me just
start yes sorry Stephanie Hoover's
virtually Tourism Organization so it's
not just the inside to calm yourself but
if you can to augment to have giggle
some roots of derivative given in the
complexity you can write as a double
stochastic matrix times root of missing
so discouraged that let's see Syria
Stephanie those rumors
give me the fact some kind yeah III
don't know hadn't looked at that sir it
would be interesting to see whether that
implies this
here remember there's this combinatorial
condition that the graph is connected
then just inside so there's kind of what
you said okay
all right okay so well that's so so what
I want to talk about the rest of the
time is is some different methods for
obtaining approximation algorithms for
partition functions and and would be
connection to phase transitions and to
both types of characterization of phase
transitions so both to the probabilistic
version and to the polynomial the
analytic version so so so I guess there
are there are three three go generic
methods that are widely used
there's Markov chain Monte Carlo
algorithms there's algorithms based on a
correlation decay and there's algorithms
based on polynomial interpolation now so
so these this is obviously as its name
suggests this is a randomized class of
algorithms this is these two both
deterministic the correlation decay
algorithms are based on the
characterization of lack of phase
transitions by uniqueness of the Gibbs
measure and there which is which is
means essentially the correlations decay
over distance and in the spin system
polynomial interpolation is based on
finding regions in which there are no
zeros of the partition function it's a
method that's recently pioneered by by
Sasha and collaborators so I'm going to
briefly discuss each of these again with
respect to our running example of easing
model and try to say a little bit about
how they might be connected and although
that's very much work in progress so so
first of all let's let's start with
Markov chain Monte Carlo and I'm not
going to say a lot about this because in
some sense this is this has been around
for a long time and it's a topic in its
own right and it's got less to do
directly with the topic of this of the
semester but I want to make some
observations about it because in in in
many cases for many spin systems it's
still the method to beat I mean somehow
there are many cases in which this does
better than than anything else and but
its randomized so so you know trying to
trying to trying to achieve similar
performance to Markov chain Monte Carlo
from these methods is tantamount to D
randomizing randomized algorithms for
partition functions and as we all we all
believe that randomization isn't
ultimately necessary we should we should
expect whenever you can do something
with a randomized algorithm in
polynomial time you should be able to do
it
deterministically as well hmm okay so
for dip for the and and and the easing
model this is why I chose this example
as a running example the easing model
had there's something interesting to say
about all of these even without leaving
the confines of the ferromagnetic using
one so so for Markov chain Monte Carlo
so what what Markov chain Monte Carlo
means that you you you you do do a
random walk on the random walk on the
set of configurations okay and usually
it's a local random walk so local local
random walk means that you eg you you
flip one spin once been at a time it's
easy to arrange the the flipping
probability so that you will converge to
the gibbs distribution in the limit so
so arrange so define so that the the
stationary distribution of the Markov
chain is is what you want
is the gibbs distribution and that's
that's because basically if you just
look at a particular spin you can reran
demise that spin based on the current
configuration of its neighbors
you know the correct marginal
probabilities for it and so you just
plug it in now if you try to apply this
to the easing model you run into you
know exactly you know on the wrong side
of the where you have the phase
transition you're going to get a problem
because so so imagine you you have very
strong interactions you've got the phase
transitions in effect so the the
stationary distribution knew the Gibbs
the Gibbs distribution kind of looks
like it has two phases really it has a
phase that's mainly almost everything is
plus and a phase in which almost
everything is minus with a little little
little imperfections so but any kind of
local dynamics that's just flipping
spins one one at a time takes a very
long time in exponential time to if you
start off for example in a configuration
like this it takes you exponential time
to make a transition so so the naive
approach Markov chain Monte Carlo
approach does not work for this problem
and again essentially because of the
phase transition because of the
existence of long-range correlations
essentially and however there is a trick
you can perform here so what you can do
is you can transform the you transform
the can the the representation of the
easing model there's something that's
called the high temperature high
temperature expansion
and the high temperature expansion the
configurations are now different so so
now the configurations are
configurations are sub graphs of G ok so
they're of the form say H the he prime
where eat prime is a subset of the edges
of the original graph and you keep all
the vertices around ok so so so so if I
have my original graph it looks like
this then I could have one of the sub
grass might be I'd be this guy and a sub
graph has has a weight and the weight is
for the weight of the sub graph weight
of H will be sy to the number of edges
in H and eater to the number of odd
degree vertices in age and where the
where this eaten and sy are defined in
terms of the original parameters so X is
get this right size either bollock
tangent of B in the original
representation which is the same as 1
minus beta over 1 plus beta in the and
the repr a motorised version we've been
working with and similarly for the other
variable
anyway so the and then and then what you
can show is that so let's let's call
this new partition function Z Z hat so
that's a function of these two new
variables and this is equal to you know
a times Z but Z of B tan lambda under
this identification of parameters where
this a is an easily computable constant
again it's some fact something that just
depends on the number of vertices and
edges of the graph so that means that
computing this thing is equivalent to
computing this thing and now if you if
you run Markov chain Monte Carlo in this
new set of configurations it turns out
that somewhere you don't see the phase
transition so this there's no obstacle
anymore to do this to to this Markov
chain not only converging to the goods
distribution but converging rapidly to
the gibbs distribution so so here so the
fact is that that local Markov chain on
these on these on these configurations
on these subgraph configurations
converges to the gibbs distribution from
any starting state
in time I mean it gets very close right
in time polynomial in the size of the
graph and in one over and by local
dynamics here I mean okay so your
configurations are now sub graphs what
you do is you just pick an edge and you
flip it either you if it isn't there
already you included or if it's already
there you take it out and you do that
with the right probability as you
converge to the correct its distribution
based on these weights this works for
every ferromagnetic yes every beetle
every beat are less than one yeah yeah
it so again throughout and unless unless
I stayed otherwise the easy models
ferromagnetic should have said that
everything I've said is this is the
number of edges of age maybe I'll I can
maybe I can just take yeah so this is
the right so the weight of it configure
yeah the weight of this configuration
would be sy cubed those are the three
edges in it and then we look at how many
odd degree vertices it has well actually
it has all of its vertices are odd so
beater to the four was just being able
to sample in polynomial time through the
Gibbs distribution presumably I could
have just added a global sign flip
transition the whole Markov chain
tonight if I if I augment with some
small number of non-local moves can I
avoid yeah that's actually not that's a
bit of an open question yeah whether
whether the only obstacle is well that's
the only obstacle and so it's basically
what you're saying is that if we add
those flips then we yeah so in general
glasses is not yeah
okay so okay so so this this is true
right for all values this this is true
for all for all parameter values okay
like I guess I've already said that
because I've included the depends only
for all for all for all sigh in the
ferromagnetic right oxide so so there's
a there's a my right so it's so so this
means that you can sample from from this
transformed gibbs distribution which
then also means that you can compute
this this partition function by standard
you know reduction from a reduction to
sampling and there's a minor detail that
you do need
you can't let eat a go to zero eta is
the you remember eater is the parameter
that corresponds to the external field
so you do need a small external field
here for this algorithm to work in other
words you do have to allow odd degree
vertices with with with not tiny
probability as you move around in this
Markov chain but it turns out that if
you so you'd be fine say Vitas about 1
over N or something like that now this
would still be polynomial and it turns
out that if you can estimate the value
of this partition function with eater
very small I 1 over and not not a
constant but something that goes to 0
with the size of the graph then you can
also estimated with eater at 0
because the two are very close okay so I
want to get into how you how you prove
this but except for one observation and
I'm making this observation to try to
make connections with other parts of the
program so it turns out that when you in
the analysis of this Markov chain
something that drops out from the
analysis in a natural way is that the
coefficients of the of this polynomial
when viewed as a polynomial in in eater
log concave so if we look at the
polynomial some you know gamma K eater
to the K where these gamma k's you know
code up the dependence on on sigh so
this is the polynomial that counts sub
graphs of a graph where K is then with K
odd degree vertices so so so K is the
number of odd degree vertices of course
K has to be even this is the polynomial
has only even coefficients and
yeah the summers on H so so did I ever
write down there's some the other so the
some Z that this polynomial which I
never wrote down I've now realized so
this polynomial Z Z hat G of e to some
over H of the weight of H all right
and this is just that polynomial viewed
as a polynomial only in the second
parameter ETA something that comes out
of the analysis of this Markov chain in
a way that's a little convoluted but it
comes out very naturally is that is that
the sequence says so the fact that you
drops out is that the sequence of
coefficients psy K is log khon kaen and
one of the exercises is to is to do the
same for the matching polynomial so
there's also a Markov chain for them for
matchings that also converges in
polynomial time and the analysis of that
has the same property that is part of
the proof the analysis of its
convergence time you actually see that
the seek than the secret the matching
polynomial has a concave coefficients so
ultra log concave so I'm not sure of
these proofs can be these are the basic
very elementary combinatorial proofs I
think I think they probably can be
strengthened to be ultra low concave and
I'm not totally sure about that
we'll see you in a moment in the
exercise okay
maybe that's a good time to stop i think
i'm so so let's pause here so i claim
the prize for the most verbose exercises
of the of the bootcamp so far
but they've a boost but they're not
actually that hard so so there are three
I don't what to do maybe take a look at
them and what are we when are we
supposed to restart 3:45 2010 have I
posed a slight a reshuffle of that so
will it take a break now and then give
you a chance to look at these and then
we can come back and talk about them at
the beginning of the next round we can
how about we every buddy okay with
restarting at 3:35 instead of 3:45 so
shifting okay
[Applause]